- I think gods in Buddhist fart.
- I'm Sara, and I am 10 years old.
- I'm four and I'm Tobie.
- By law, I am Jewish, but I don't know
if I necessarily believe in it.
- I believe in Buddhism.
- I believe in God.
- For me, it's a really big maybe.
Part of me believes in God a lot,
and part of me definitely doesn't.
Because maybe there is someone upstairs,
making great things happen
and sprinkling magic on the world.
And then you see such bad stuff happen
and you see kids get cancer,
you doubt or you question God.
- We have this thing called Guanyin,
it's kind of like God,
but it's like Chinese.
- In my religion, we call him Allah.
- He helps people.
- God is love.
- I think God has a sweet, soft voice.
- I think he would sound
like, "Hi" (laughs).
- I think since he's lived so long,
it's kind of washed out, "I should make
"good things happen to the world."
This sounds so creepy,
like a horror movie.
- I think it sounds loud.
He sounds like really kind, I think.
"Well hello" (laughs).
- You can see him on the ground
on his legs and on his feet.
- I think God is in the sky.
- I pray to the Guanyin
to bring us good luck
and support my family.
- Usually what I wish for,
I'd like to spend time
with my mom all day.
- I wanna have confidence in God,
if they control all of us,
I wanna have confidence
that I don't need to pray
and tell them to do it.
I think they should
make great things happen
and really prevent the
really bad, terrible things.
- One time I went outside
and I prayed to God
so I could have flowers.
- If there is a God, what is it?
What do they look like?
- God looks like a person.
- Maybe God's a woman
or maybe God doesn't identify as a gender.
- They're usually gold or white.
- I think God will have green eyes.
- Why do we always think
of him wearing a hoodie?
- I'm drawing him clothes,
I don't really know if he has clothes
because I can't draw him naked.
- He's wearing his masculine God t-shirt.
Gotta put that God on there.
- Put some jewelry on his head.
- He's in his hoodie so we're not gonna
be able to see his hair, guys.
I don't think he has hair,
I think it's hard to keep having hair
if you've been alive for
this many millions of years.
He's kinda self-conscious
about not having hair.
- This one's shaped like a monkey.
- I just would hope that he would look
like a regular person.
- God is a big head on legs (laughs).
- His hands are very long and big.
- I now how to make hands, really.
Like this circle,
because my hands are circles, see?
- I don't think he looks
like anyone I know.
- I think he wears those swag green pants,
very cool green pants, make
him a little more colorful.
He's got those sick Nikes on.
- He has a beard.
- He has orange hair
and green eyes (laughs).
- He's big and he always sits down.
- He looks kinda funny.
- He has a blue shirt and blue pants,
and very hairy arms.
- I just would like you to think of God,
a man or a woman or whatever you want
to think of God as, happiness.
You should have big smile
when you think of God.
And wearing those, those
sick Nikes, you know.
- Thank you for letting
me be in this world.
- The world goes around because all these
different people have
different beliefs in God,
and I love that, but I don't think
that their beliefs should cause wars.
This could be somewhat fiction.
This could be somewhat man-made.
I love that everyone has
a different view of God
and different beliefs in God,
but I don't think it should
cause so much commodity or war,
I really don't.
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new
channel, and now your part.
- [Together] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.